hey at the hour fam just want to give a
little bit of an introduction to this
episode 29 this conversation with rabbi
angela buchdall we're actually releasing
a different day this week just with
everything that we've experienced as a
society i'm recording this uh intro on
the 26th of may and i debated uh for a
while on whether to release the episode
this week where they give some time just
as we've continued to
experience tragedy after tragedy with
these uh with these shootings first um
not first but recently in buffalo then
again in california
in texas in elementary school um and so
i debated whether to release this
episode because some of the topics that
we brought up were also related to that
in the sense that rabbi buchdall also
walked
a hot walk through and helps navigate a
hostage situation in the synagogue in
texas in january and that's something
that she talked about on the episode as
well um so i just wanted to be sensitive
to where we all were as a society where
you all were as listeners but ultimately
i thought it would still be good to
release the episode because there's so
many aspects of hope that she also
shared in this episode in terms of just
things that she has been navigating as a
leader things that she has navigated in
her synagogue and in her jewish
community and i think important lessons
for us all so again that's the reason
that we decided to wait and not release
this episode the day after the tragic
shooting our hearts go out to all those
families not even being able to imagine
what it's like to lose a child in that
type of setting on such
an unfortunate circumstance and in so
many ways obviously there are lots of
policy implications that we could
actually do better to try and prevent
these things from happening
so with that being said i just want to
make sure that i put this in context i
hope that you all still will take the
time to process and to mourn to grieve
as you need to but also to know that we
are here for each other and we need to
support each other in this time i think
that's something you'll definitely get
in this episode as well but again just
wanted to put things in context and to
let you all know about that but i
encourage you to listen to the episode
so many important things that we were
able to discuss and i believe that
you'll find it cathartic and healing in
some ways as well i appreciate you all
always uh being here as an addie our
family and for everything that you all
do to invest in this podcast
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour i'm grateful to continue to
host these conversations i will say on
the front end we are operating in a
spirit of flexibility today as we've
been navigating some technical
challenges but again it's so important
for us to just be flexible in this
moment and something that i've been
saying to a lot of people so it makes
sense that i would have to move in that
space as well but again grateful that
you all continue to join these
conversations actually recording in the
yale podcast studio again today so
thankful for the team and for all
they've done to really just help us
facilitate these conversations over the
last year and a half
today i'm honored to be able to welcome
dr oh my goodness rabbi that's something
i've done to multiple guests
you're not the first but
to introduce rabbi angela book doll who
is here joining us for a conversation
today so grateful to have you here on
the podcast grateful to be here
and for today's conversation it's just
going to be an open conversation on a
lot of different topics i haven't
assigned a specific title or theme which
is a little bit different for us but
again i think as you all listen into
this conversation you'll see why that's
the case because there's so many
important things that we may touch on as
we go through
so just by way of introduction for any
who aren't familiar or familiar with uh
with the rabbi i just wanted to mention
her background a little bit she serves
as a senior rabbi of central synagogue
in new york city and was his first woman
to lead the first woman to lead
central's reform congregation in its 180
year history
so rabbi buchdall first joined central
synagogue as a senior cantor in 2006 and
in 2014 she was chosen by the
congregation to be the senior rabbi
she was born in korea to a jewish
american father and a korean buddhist
mother
later in life she earned attended and
earned a bachelor's degree in arts and
religious studies from
yale university here on campus and of
course later became ordained as the
first asian american to be ordained as a
cantor or rabbi in north america so
someone who is a pioneer and a
trailblazer in a lot of ways
she's been naturally recognized in a lot
of different ways and also for her
innovations in leading worship she's
been featured in dozens of news outlets
including the today show npr and pbs and
was also listed as one of newsweek's
america's 50 most influential rabbis
angelo is someone who also serves on a
lot of different organizations and
boards on the agc also on the new york
board of rabbis on the uja federation of
new york and on the yale university
president's council
she's married to her husband jacob and
they have three children so again
someone that i've been introduced to and
have had the pleasure of being able to
interact with a little bit and really
looking forward to the conversation this
afternoon so thanks so much for being
here
me too you left out that i am
was the
college roommate of dr esther chu who
was our point of connection to begin
with and uh you know my claim to fame in
the doctor
[Laughter]
maybe that's where where the doctor
parts looked for me maybe that's what it
was perhaps i'm elevating you but i
think
you know humorous eye there are so many
things that you have so much um
influence and impact and as well so who
knows maybe that's something that will
come in honorary at some point in the
future but i'm starting that today but
yes definitely appreciate that
recognition of dr chu uh connecting the
two of us and appreciate her investment
in what we're doing here as well
so again just to start out as you know
and as my listeners know i think it's so
important for us to have check-ins with
each other as we engage in some of these
conversations and especially as as we're
recording at this point in time um in
the middle of may the third week of may
obviously this has been another
challenging
week for our country even as we have
been mourning the loss of so many lives
first in buffalo with a tragic situation
there also in california and also just
acknowledging that a lot of these things
are ongoing even events that don't
necessarily hit the national news media
in a sense
but at the same time we have a lot of
room also for joy as we see people
collectively supporting each other in so
many different ways as we have reasons
for hope and so with those two things in
mind just want to check in with you and
see how you're doing at this point in
time with everything that we're
navigating through as a society
and you know i think i i'm feeling what
a lot of people this country are feeling
which is a mix of
despair and
deep upset and hurt
over recent
devastating gun violence racial hatred
that we're seeing
you know
last two weeks ago the news about the
leaked decision about abortion in the
supreme court and where we might be
heading with women's rights and i just
you know there's a lot that we are very
concerned about and i think that it for
me as a person who works in um
the religious field i think that uh
spiritual resilience like part of the
work now is that we actually
keep up our sense of spiritual
resilience to have the will to not give
in to that despair to to actually
believe that and remind ourselves that
change is always happening and is
continues to be possible change for the
better um and that um you know i think
that that's that's where we are right
now and i actually have to keep
reminding myself of that message at
times
really well said i i take that to heart
as well even in terms of the the
reminders that we have to give ourselves
how would you say that you're those in
your um
your congregation are also navigating
through all this as well
in terms of what you've seen in them and
then also in your role as a leader
i think that i think people are
experiencing this on different levels
some some are taking it very personally
some are experiencing it with a great
deal of fear and anxiety and there are
others that have kind of built up a wall
and um and actually have stopped being
able to stop listening to the news
stopped actually caring i don't know
actually what is more frightening we
often talk about the fact that
indifference is um one of the uh
gravestones because it sort of enables
and allows all of this to happen so i
think you know i don't i don't think
there's just one response that i'm
seeing
and uh
you know i think there's a certain kind
of process that people go through when
they're grieving something or
experiencing a trauma of some kind that
um some of these things are are that for
people and um and you have to help
people move through it to a place that
is a little with a little bit more
healing a little more productive
a little more hopeful so i think that's
that's the task
i appreciate how sensitive it sounds
like you are to just all the different
places that people are um and even you
know to take it a step further i think
for many of us we're also in a lot of
those different places at different
times so you know at one moment it might
be for me you know trying
walking through mourning at another
moment outrage and frustration
sometimes some despair as well like oh
this is happening again are things ever
going to get better and just knowing
that there needs to be time and place
for all those pieces and it sounds like
you're really
empathetic to that and and cognizant of
that as you're in such a an important
leadership role as well so that's
definitely something i appreciate and i
imagine that those um and you're saying
i would appreciate that level of empathy
and awareness as well so i just wanted
to acknowledge that
thank you
so obviously a lot that we're walking
through and again just in your role as a
leader a lot that you also often have to
carry with you
yourself and as you're leading others as
well so i know we'll come back to that
in the conversation but i also want to
take a step back a little bit as well
because you know as i was just
mentioning your introduction and your
path there's a lot there there's a lot
of important components there there's a
lot of trailblazing there and i was just
curious if you'd be willing to share
with our listeners a little bit about
your path and your journey
from you know
growing up to come becoming in this this
esteemed role and someone who is
pioneering in so many different ways how
did that journey come about for you
well
so much of this with so much of life is
um
a product of uh
some fortunate timing and luck um as
well as just you know i think um people
following
a calling if they're able to listen to
what they're sort of called to do and so
i certainly never
set out as a little kid to think to
myself oh i want to be a first of
anything honestly um or a trailblazer i
what i was doing was sort of listening
to a call that i had from a pretty young
age that i was very attuned to sort of
the spirit of the universe um and i i
received in many ways my spiritual
um
sensitivity from my buddhist mother but
then i received a sort of spiritual and
ritual vocabulary from my jewish father
with the jewish community in which i was
raised so i think that um you know
actually jews many
many jews are not actually that
comfortable talking about god um it
might surprise you it's not like many
other faith traditions in which people
very comfortably talk about it but the
vast majority of jews that are in sort
of progressive circles
um
at best you could say many of them are
sort of uncomfortable talking about it
but so i think my mother gave me a sense
of
comfort not just talking about god but
actually being in conversation with god
on a regular basis um and and then i
think but my but the fact that my father
um and my mother decided that my sister
and i would be raised within the jewish
community gave us sort of a a ritual
yearly structure for holidays and
shabbat gatherings and meals and um
and biblical stories that sort of
informed the way that i walk through the
world so in some ways a foundation was
set early um i'm not a typical uh
not a typical path to the rabbinate as
like an immigrant from south korea who
comes to america grows up in a tiny
jewish community in tacoma washington
and goes on to lead a large synagogue in
new york
um
you know that is an unusual story but in
many ways part of the luck of this is
that i was born in 1972 which was the
year that the very first female rabbi
was ordained so it's it's 50 years this
year that the first woman was ordained
which in the scope of 3 000 years of
jewish history that's just a blink um
and
at the same time there was not a day of
my lifetime
that i didn't think it was possible for
a woman to be a rabbi so in that way i
was very lucky i was also lucky my
parents were married in 1969 this was
just a year after loving versus virginia
which meant that interracial marriage
was not outlawed in some of our states
in america so here my parents were um
only a year later
you know we're getting married at a time
when people were still getting
accustomed to the idea of interracial
marriages and
i was fortunate that you know that their
love was not illegal in any state by the
time they got married but only barely um
i was lucky that i was born at a time
when um title ix passed and it you know
it took a place like yale which had only
just right before i was born a few years
before started to take women but you
know for a while was still only wanting
to keep women to about 15 percent of the
college until title nine came around and
then they were forced to have to
actually go 50 50. they did not want to
go there willingly so i think about
these kinds of things that all
contributed to this path that ultimately
um i got to be on and i and i recognize
how many shoulders i'm standing on in
order to have been able to be a woman
who could become a rabbi who could have
a korean mother who could end up leading
a community and the last thing i'd say
is that the reform movement which is the
progressive movement of the jewish
community
made a decision in the late 70s that
they were actually going to be welcoming
of interfaith families for a long time
the policy because it's a it's a
community that really values endogamy
and jews marrying jews for jewish
continuity's sake um
its policy used to be
we're going to reject anyone if uh who
marries outside of the faith um if you
ever saw fiddler on the roof which is
a lot of people's jewish introduction
you know they literally sit shiva they
say they say the the death prayer for
the person who has married out
um
it was a controversial and very brave
decision that um that the movement took
in the 70s to say actually this is not
good for jewish continuity what's going
to be good for for our our community is
for us to welcome those who um marry out
so i was also coming to america just at
a time when the jewish community's
attitudes were changing towards families
just like mine so all of these things
contribute to how i got to be where i am
and it's a confluence of you know gender
equality issues that were just coming of
age racial acceptance and interfaith and
inter-religious and interracial couples
that were just becoming um acceptable in
society just as i was um being born into
a family that was all of those things so
um i i i recognized that if i'd been
born a generation earlier or even 10
years earlier my life could not be
possible as it unfolded so i think about
that a lot and and frankly because i'm a
person of faith
i think that there was a sense of um
this is why i'm called to be in this
place right now because i could
and because i think the generations
before me probably could not
wow i mean that's such a helpful
perspective you know as i'm listening to
you share all those different aspects um
you know some may say serendipity but i
mean there's so many that you just
listed in terms of timing had things
been fi even not even a generational but
five years ago or just all so many
pieces that were in place so
it's just i think that's it's actually
very encouraging for me to hear how
front and center of that perspective
seems to be for you i mean it doesn't
sound like in any sense it's forgotten
or you had to dig deep to pull it back
up but it's there kind of on the tip of
your tongue that you know exactly how
each of these
different perspectives really well
i will be honest with you um when i got
to yale in the 90s
i was not i would not i would think of
myself not as like a reluctant feminist
or i didn't quite understand why do we
still have a women's center like
where the job of feminism is done i feel
so naive thinking about myself that way
but that was sort of the way i felt then
because i i felt like i could do
anything a man could do it wasn't until
i got actually a little bit older or
started having kids hit the glass
ceiling for the first time that i
actually appreciated that actually oh we
still have so much work to do in fact if
anything i became the angry feminist in
my 40s you know
i but i would say the reason in part
that i'm able to reflect on this now is
actually i'm working on a memoir and
it's funny how you look back on these
things and suddenly all those pieces
kind of came into place and i don't
think it took some maturity honestly
from um and some retrospection to
actually think about
how many sort of social movements had to
to lay the foundation for where i could
be um and it made me appreciate that
fight so much more it made me realize
first of all that we're obviously not
done with any of those fights um from
feminism to racial justice to you know
acceptance across lines of difference
and all of those things but um it made
me appreciate that first of all we've
made some progress even though we have
work to do and
it made me um
reflect on it in a way that i actually
frankly when i was younger
didn't appreciate honestly yeah that
makes a lot of sense and i appreciate
your honesty and giving that us that
perspective as well which this is gonna
sound funny but i think it's hopeful for
many of us as well to feel like well
there's always room for growth even as
you've stated that so importantly but
some of the things that you may not have
realized and i had to look back on that
are now so fresh and and clear to you as
well and again just in your story i mean
there's so many important elements that
are there even from the family dynamic
and the empowerment you had there to
some of the things and movements that
were happening
but i'm also thinking just in terms of
the importance of policy i mean a lot of
the things that you referenced were
policies that were changed that had
direct impact on your ability to move
forward in certain circles um that's
something that comes up in so many
different ways i mean i can think about
that on the research side with some of
the work that we're doing for instance
around e-cigarettes and how policy can
influence and impact
aspects of of health when it comes to
you know youth who may be using
e-cigarettes young people or adults and
all those types of
processes but even as you mentioned
around all the diversity equity
inclusion anti-racism how the policy can
have direct impacts on people's lives i
think in a lot of different ways
sometimes we like to acknowledge that
and sometimes it seems like we pretend
that that's not the case that these
things are just philosophical
conversations when there's so much more
to it as well so i mean so much of what
you said is resonating with me as well
and i'm attempting not to become too
tangential but i think it's just i mean
everything you share is such a concrete
example of so many ways that has
happened
in your life that has been beneficial to
you as a person as an individual who has
grown and has also allowed you to have
so much impact in so many ways as well
so i'm just reflecting as you're talking
and
piecing all those things together and
appreciative again of the way that
you've been able to just um describe
that and already looking forward to
whatever this memoir is that you just
referenced
as well so unfortunately my day job
keeps me from having a lot of time to
write but i've done a little more
reflection so that's good yeah yeah
speaking of the day job i'm also just
curious you know as you've taken us on
this journey a little bit how do people
respond to your journey both within the
jewish community but the community at
large because i can anticipate and
imagine that were different responses
and reactions in different circles i'm
just curious what that was like from
your perspective
you know i think that uh
you have to have a sense of humor about
it and i think that um you know when i
was younger i mean there wasn't a single
time i could walk into a
new jewish community and not get lots
and lots of questions and and they could
come from
places of genuine curiosity and you know
welcome and they could sometimes come
from a place of challenge and ignorance
and um sometimes uh mean-spiritedness um
and i think you know the question that i
got was some variation of that's funny
you don't look jewish or you know how
are you possibly jewish or whatever it
was and um
you know
none of those things feel like massively
um uh threatening in in any sort of
single instance but if it's sort of your
experience every time you walk into a
community you you feel constantly
othered you feel kind of constantly like
you don't really belong
and like a stranger and so there was a
certain aspect of that that was a
defining feature of what it was like to
walk into a new jewish community um
that being said once i was in a
community like my home community in
tacoma you know it didn't take long
before people um
just saw me as angela you know and as a
jew and as part of the community
um and they were open to what i could
contribute and how i wanted to be a part
of it and so i mean i think that i
obviously couldn't be a rabbi today if i
didn't get a lot of support and love and
sense of meaning from
people along the way mentors jewish
community members like you know my
surrogate aunties and and uncles and
like congregations who really
welcomed me and were extremely loving so
you know i think that the good news is
you get past that sort of initial
um
how are you jewish and
you know and and then you just establish
yourself in a day and so i would say you
know i'm now at a stage in my career
where people know who i am and i don't
get the same questions and i think i
mistakenly kind of felt like okay well
i'm the i'm the senior rabbi of a large
manhattan congregation with a lot of
jews of color within my congregation and
i thought okay well since i'm here at
the front it's things are all better
right well recently in light of the
george floyd um murder and just
many more conversations sort of a
national reckoning that we were all
having as a country around race
people in my community came out of the
woodwork and shared their own stories of
racism within the jewish community and i
i think i didn't appreciate
that their experience was still so much
more like mine was 20 years ago and it
it wasn't enough that i was the senior
rabbi there was still ways that our
community was not um responding as i
kind of had hoped and so i think you
know i ended up giving a sermon about
this um i knew that i it kind of the
most holy day of the year when i have
the most people watching on yom kippur
um where i have thousands in my
congregation watching and then hundreds
of thousands watching on live stream
i knew i wanted to address racism in our
country coming off of um the summer that
we'd had when george floyd was murdered
i didn't realize until i started to sit
down and write the sermon that
ultimately i had to start actually with
what i
understood was the racism that was still
existent within our community i felt
like you have to start with your own
house
and our own house still had work to do
and i recognize that this is a muscle
that you have to actually exercise a
muscle of fighting your biases um it's
not usually coming i don't i believe
people usually come from a pretty good
place i don't think most people are
trying to actually make anyone feel
othered or make them feel like they
don't belong they don't understand that
their questions they often come out of
curiosity or ignorance
ends up actually um having that impact
on people and so i realized that i
needed to talk about that first and once
you actually work on that muscle in your
own community you actually start to
understand what it feels like to be more
cognizant of that in the rest of the
world so i i just i saw it as something
that was really important to start with
the jewish community first and that
sermon had an impact that i've never had
any other sermon have it basically kind
of went viral for a sermon in the jewish
world and um
and i think that it it was hitting at a
particular time again timing is
everything where the community was
willing to think about it and listen and
it's really shaped the conversation for
our community kind of moving forward how
we're prioritizing some of these
questions and i think a sensitivity to
the way that we're responding and
talking to each other in in our own
community so you know i now have a jews
of color group at my synagogue which is
not a group that existed before and
and i think that the idea is we don't
want to be remain separate but we also
want to have a safe space to talk about
some of those things that are still
challenging and um
you know that group for example wanted
to have a have a meeting and talk post
buffalo about what it is to be both a
person who might be black and and jewish
and there's sort of that some of the
hatred that was coming out of the
gunman's mouth was um
both you know this replacement theory
idea of that both is rooted in deeply
anti-semitic views as well as
um anti-a racist views um against blacks
so i think that um
it's been really a very interesting
journey um to think about what this
means i would say that uh i credit my
community for um
absolutely for embracing me and i think
ultimately the people in our community
with all of all of its diversity i mean
ironically that one thing i would say is
i think that when i wanted to become the
senior rabbi um i'd already been in my
congregation for eight years as the
senior cantor and so i was known in the
community and um i don't think that it
was an issue at all anymore that i was
asian but it was very interesting that
it was an issue that i was a woman um
because that was the that that was the
gap for people you know at the time
there was not another woman leading a
large synagogue in in all of new york
like um there was there still is not a
woman in manhattan leading a
synagogue that's a large synagogue and
we have you know a dozen of them so i
think that there is still it's 50 years
which is i said feels like a long time
but it's also not that long and we just
haven't quite gotten there yet and so
for them the bigger leap was imagining a
woman
in charge they were they had become
comfortable with the woman in a number
two position but i think it's very
different um and there it came out in
different ways that i i felt when i was
applying for that job um eventually
people
uh selected me so i i think that
obviously it wasn't enough to for people
to not kind of say we're ready to take
this leap but it's interesting how my
president
who um at the time
said that as soon as it was announced we
actually happened to go to a large
convention of jews called the biennial
gathering um a week later he said he
could not believe how many people said
to him
what a brave decision you made and he
thought wow they're really
characterizing this is like it's brave
to name a korean female rabbi as the
head of central synagogue um and so
you know that just gives you a sense of
where that was that was you know nine
years ago yeah wow such a
helpful perspective all the things you
shared and especially that last uh last
component as well um but just to to go
back a little bit i mean i'm just
i'm impressed and encouraged one that
your willingness to lean in in your own
house and for the ways that people seem
to go along on that journey with you and
really have that introspection because
even as you were talking i was imagining
just ways that people could react in
that situation which is based on all the
things we've seen in so many different
ways of denial or or because like you
said even if it's not from a place of
intentional hurt that can sometimes put
up a wall in the barrier where people
don't really want to acknowledge what's
there so as much as people are willing
to lead into that conversation and you
know to you to be able to listen to what
people are bringing
uh bringing to you as well um but to
your last one i think that just speaks
of where things are and again this is me
speculating but you being in this role
as a woman and people trusting you and
entering into that space with you and
walking through these hard topics
because obviously they are different
difficult challenges for any of us to
walk through but it seems like there's
more and more layers there as they're
looking to you as a leader but also
having to reconcile the fact that
you are one of the few especially in in
your area and and how that has also
likely had an impact i mean even that
comment about people saying that was the
brave decision that's very reflective in
a lot of ways about people's perceptions
and
not only like they were saying that for
the you know the president and whoever
was involved to make that decision but
it seems like that would also have an
impact on people being willing to follow
in a sense not that they're following
you they're ultimately following god in
the higher power but you in that role as
a facilitator so again i'm just kind of
reflecting as you're sharing um all
those pieces
but one one other question that did come
to mind is just you know as you
mentioned that there aren't other women
of large synagogues who are in this same
type of leadership role what has that
process been like for you i mean is
there enough not that you don't have a
cohort among your peers but has that
is that uh
then we'll call it attention but i'm
just curious i guess how that experience
has been for you i don't want to
pre-label it or presuppose
just to kind of give you room to comment
on that as well i guess the good news i
would say is that it really has changed
even since i've been in this role for
eight years now so since i was named
nine years ago um it is it has changed
there's a
you know um a woman was named to a large
congregation in brooklyn and then soon
after you know up in
toronto and so you know so not yet in
manhattan as many um although there are
i certainly have female colleagues but
of like the large communities that you
started to see it changing in the last
especially five years and um so that's
also been encouraging and i'm part of a
larger rabbi cohort that studies
together in jerusalem every year and
that now has a like a real cadre of like
um
strong women rabbis so that's been
wonderful but i still when i sit at
tables um and especially interfaith
tables uh i often am still like the only
woman in the room part of a religious
coalition that is that is organized by
the cardinal um colonel dolan here in
new york and there literally were no
women at that table um and i actually
opened my big mouth and said i noticed
that you know this is a coalition of
religious leaders you don't have a
single woman sitting at this table of
your executive group so you open your
big mouth then you get invited so i have
to show up now there are two of us
but you know the fact is that um
in many faith traditions they still do
not have women in positions of religious
leadership with specific kinds of titles
and so it's not just about um
uh
my own faith tradition it's in the
larger faith world and space there's
still there's still real barriers for
women the stained glass ceiling we call
it and um
and i you know i think there's still a
lot of work here and the implications
are not just that you're losing
50 of the potential you know leadership
that you could have
i actually think it's even more
dramatic than that in terms of what is
lost i think that people's theology is
shaped by
the people who convey the message um and
it's just interesting i mean people i
used to grow up and say things like oh
um
rabbi stern he was a rabbi of a
community that i used to lead
his voice was the voice of god that's
what i imagined god's voice to sound
like right it was jack stern and believe
me he was a brilliant preacher i could
imagine god sounding like jack stern but
that that kind of refrain of like the
voice of god being their rabbi just as
the transmitter
think about what that does for your
conception of it now what's interesting
is now that i'm the senior rabbi i don't
actually think that people think that
god sounds like me as much as now i
think actually they understand god in a
totally different way a little less like
from on high i think it's partly
generational i think it's partly the way
women are perceived um and i don't want
to make huge generalizations but i think
that it's shifted our theology it's
shifted our religious language it's
shifted the way we create community it's
so much deeper than just whether or not
we can put women in positions when
you're talking about spiritual
leadership it actually impacts the
entire way you actually think about the
life of the spirit so i think that um
it's profound the change that's happened
in 50 years since women have entered the
rabbinate in our community yeah yeah
that's really wonderful to hear and it
seems like it's just like you mentioned
just perspective in a lot of ways too um
and so many aspects of
i mean when we think about the
reflection of god in the community it's
not
one or the other it's it's
all people so to hear you to speak about
those things and just the practical ways
you've seen that is just
also also encouraging as well and i
imagine it's having i would imagine
having just generational will have
generational impacts as well i guess
some of that remains to be seen but i'm
just you know thinking forward in that
realm as well and so definitely
appreciate the way that you've brought
so many of those things to light and
then all the work that you're continuing
to do because i imagine that's not light
work um even as we have already been
talking about um and on that i mean i'm
just
balance is a word that i use
cautiously at this point in time but i'm
wondering just to kind of move the
conversation a little bit outside of
your specific role but also think about
how you attempt to balance or
juggle or manage as it were all the many
different
roles that you have and responsibilities
even in the midst of the things that
continue to happen because you talked
about some of the communities that
you've
been involved in in your own
congregation the groups that have
started up even the conversation you had
the last few days about the situation in
buffalo so how do you manage your time
from that standpoint to still be able to
invest and serve
in your congregation in the community
but then also to be able to have people
pour into you as well
um you know balance i think what does
that word mean i think the image that
comes to mind is like being on one of
those like little seat of the like those
teeter-totters right where like you put
your leg on each side and like you know
the idea that you get to a point of
bounce maybe you're like i got it and
then you're like
the entire time all you're doing is
adjusting
i think that's kind of what i think my
balance has been like it's just
constantly adjusting every once in a
while i can have a moment where like ah
it's just i'm in balance and then then
it's back so you know i think um i don't
know if that's what i'm going for i
think i want to be able to feel like at
the end of the day the things that i
have paid attention to
which is ultimately going to be what my
life is made up of that those are the
things that i wanted to have paid
attention to and i've gotten better
about
calendaring that into my life so that
like i actually make sure that i
calendar in um you know
my you know
daughter's like you know basketball game
i make and then if that's in there that
i'm not just programming around um or
scheduling over it um that i actually
you know make sure i have time for my
meditation that is part of my own um
personal practice or um you know going
and exercising a little bit so i can
have like mental and physical health so
i think that you know what i've gotten
better about is scheduling that and
working my life um to make sure that
those elements in
sometimes it has to get canceled
sometimes it has to get moved but you
know it's that that constant work um one
of the things i have come to understand
better
and it probably took till about 10 years
ago when i finally started doing more um
spiritual practice work and meditation
is it i used to think of
things like taking care of myself uh
self-care has like all sorts of
connotations that can sometimes be you
know problematic but i used to think of
it as in some way sort of indulgent
and i went on my first sort of spiritual
practice retreat with the institute for
jewish spirituality i guess it's already
like 10 years ago um five days mostly
mostly silent meditation retreat um and
with some learning and some yoga and a
lot of meditation and it was like a
revelation for me it sort of it sort of
helped me understand that and that when
i am actually not feeling in some ways
whole there's really no i've got nothing
left to give in some way and so i
started to understand that caring for
myself is a form of caring for god uh
for caring for others and um and so i
don't feel as apologetic for making that
time that i think i used to in my
younger days feel much more
much more that way um
it's still hard to find finally and um
and i think you know i think that's
that's continued work yeah well i
appreciate you sharing that as well as i
think so many people
have started to pay much more attention
to that and it's just refreshing and
encouraging to hear you stating that as
a leader as well
just knowing how important that time is
i mean you know one humorous example i
always share with people is just the
lack of a commute for me personally not
realizing how much of that i use for
processing when that commute turned into
the one-minute commute from the attic
makeshift office back to home life and
homework and all the other things that
come with that realizing just feeling
like things were more frazzled and so no
oh that wasn't
having that time was actually helpful
and i didn't realize how much i was
using it to process and reset and just
have balance in that sense as well so
you hear you talk about those retreats
that you've taken how important that is
and then you know even thinking from a
biblical reference standpoint to if our
bodies are temples and are we actually
taking care of our temples or just
output output output all the time with
no care for that so i appreciate you
walking us through that as well and the
importance of scheduling sometimes it
makes it feel i guess less
well it is less spontaneous and less
meaningful but i think at the end of the
day like you mentioned it's just
important to have those pieces and to
know that there is mean that comes from
that intentional scheduling of that
basketball game for your daughter and
how important that is for both of you so
right definitely appreciate you well i
mean and i think this wisdom of just the
importance of some of that time i mean
that is a foundational principle of
judaism that we are actually not meant
to work
um day in day out and create every day
of the week we actually have to take
a rest and and shabbat is actually um
not just
utilitarian so that we can rest up so we
can go back and work it's actually the
point of it all and um i would say that
maybe the most profound spiritual
practice of my life is that i really do
make shabbat for myself and my family
and that has sustained us you know even
even though um in my field of work i
work on friday nights and lead services
to me though leading services is when
i'm in the flow and i i i my tremendous
joy and it does not that does not feel
like the work of my job at all um and
and you know in the saturday morning i
often am leading services although i'm
also off some because i have a big team
and we share the responsibilities so
you know but but saturday afternoon we
are almost always having a long
leisurely unencumbered shabbat lunch um
with other families with our whole
family with no electronics and it is um
luxuriousness of
space and time and nothing scheduled and
i think there is something about the
boundaries of like i can't do anything
else but just be
that actually creates tremendous freedom
and and it is there's such wisdom i
think if i could encourage everyone and
i don't mean just people who are jewish
but all people to truly feel bound to
take one day um without creating or
doing or feeling ambitious but just to
be feel like
this moment
i don't have to do anything but just be
with the people i love exist um enjoy
take joy
i it is life-changing really yeah i 100
agree with you and appreciate that
reminder for all of us and the
importance of it um and again just
impressed with how this because it is
disciplined the way that you're talking
about as well yeah
discipline in some ways i'm i you know i
didn't grow up in a tradition where i
felt that that was my religious
obligation i grew up in a
less kind of observant home and actually
there's a part of me that was very
jealous of people who felt like
commanded by god in that sort of
traditional way to like not work um
and it took me a while to get to the
place of recognizing that that
commandedness
was real and can come internally and you
can decide to take your life in that way
and um and and you know and live your
life in that way um so many of us feel
like we don't have control over our
lives that way and
you know i i think we have to push back
on that yeah yeah 100 agree and just the
the the life and the freedom that comes
from that um and even just from even
from a neuroscience to expectation we
can look forward to that and have that
control and just all the all the ways
that i mean so many aspects of what you
talked about just even being in
community with one another in that space
and in that time without all the outside
pressures and just how benefit how
beneficial that is for us as human
beings um
you know as as god's creation and just
what it does to being communion trying
not to pull in all the things from our
previous episodes with oxytocin and
communion
but all that is there as well and you
know i'll let people listen to previous
episodes to really dig deep into that
but it's so refreshing in some ways you
know even in these conversations that we
have to see so many of these things come
from different components from what we
know from our faith traditions from what
we know and are learning from the
neuroscience of psychology and to know
that these things are for our benefit
and there's a reason that we should
strive to keep those disciplines i
really
i love that i kind of geek out on
finding out you know the science that
supports the thing that religious
tradition has been telling us to do all
along i love that you know it just kind
of confirms the wonder of this but i
think it's part of it is that you have
to imagine a religious tradition that
has evolved over thousands of years it's
it's you know
and it i think it really truly does
exist um its purpose is to kind of help
shape people's lives as lives of meaning
um
and value and purpose and and also help
reinforce community which is so deeply
important i think in a time when people
feel more isolated than they've ever
felt more you know lonely um lacking
meaning and direction um i think that
religion is the antidote i mean i think
spirituality for me
um it's not just about believing in god
in fact it doesn't have to be that
language which i recognize has a lot of
baggage for people i think um maybe
maybe one of the best um explanations
i've i've heard and i don't know where i
heard this so i'm sorry i can't quote it
um but
i'll share it
is that you know the opposite of
spirituality is not atheism or
agnosticism the opposite is narcissism
so if a spiritual life is really truly
to help you get out of your own head
to help you actually understand you are
part of something much bigger than
yourself you're part of a bigger story
you're obligated to something beyond
yourself um that to me is the entire
purpose of what a spiritual life should
be
and i think every faith tradition offers
structure ritual teachings for that um i
think every religious tradition can be
corrupted as well and can be taken to
extremes but i think every faith
tradition offers offers the ability for
each human being to really find their
purpose into and understand themselves
out of the
smallness of their individual life and
in the context of something eternal and
much bigger yeah yeah so well said yeah
100 agree and it's it's just again so
refreshing and beautiful here he's
speaking about that as well and
all the ways that we we really need to
continue to to move that conversation
forward and as you mentioned just some
part of something bigger and part of a
larger community you know how important
that is for so many of us especially you
know even as we let off this
conversation just saying that we have
seen aspects of ways communities have
come together in the midst of the
challenges that we're facing and ways
that it was more difficult for us to do
that when we were in isolation
so again i'm hoping that we hold on to
those aspects and we don't forget those
things you know as we are you know back
in society in a sense or emerging or
re-emerging or whatever state people are
in because there's a whole
range of different states that people
are walking through that but i think
it's such an important thing for us to
be able to hold on to
um in so many ways and also this makes
me think of unity the importance of
unity i mean especially you know i know
i keep harping back to what happened in
the past
you know in the past week but it's been
i think an opportunity for us to have
uni i've even seen you know some things
on social media just talking about well
opportunities for those in jewish
communities in black and brown
communities and other communities to
come together around some of these
unfortunately common tragic situations
that many of us are walking through
especially you know even in asian
american and pacific islander
communities and the diversity that that
community has but what are the ways that
we can kind of
move together in union to make sure that
these things
are addressed head-on even as you've
talked about in your own congregation so
i know that's different than what we've
been saying but that still comes to mind
when i think about these aspects of
community and i think about these
aspects of having discipline to sit down
and to pause and to rest and refresh and
just be in the presence of one another
um so again it just it makes me think
that this is just full circle in a lot
of ways
at the same time even as you're talking
about some of these diplomas and i know
that there are often things that do come
up i mean situations come up that throw
us from that
disciplined
arena we have to have you know margins
for flexibility and adjustments for
impromptu conversations and those types
of things so it's going to have you
share about how that happens in your
life um as well but also just want to
highlight for those who don't know you
know a very specific situation where
that happened for you um back in january
when you received a call from a a gunman
who had congregants
um in a hostage situation um in texas
and how you responded to that situation
in a very quick thinking manner um so
wonder if you just as much as you want
to kind of take us through that and what
you learned in that moment because again
obviously something that wasn't planned
that didn't fit into your normal routine
but that you had to respond to and also
i would imagine to decide how urgent is
this in actuality
well i i
received a voicemail on shabbat
afternoon after services from
a rabbi
who let me know that he was being held
hostage with three others
by a gunman who was has had bombs and
had a gun and was threatening their
lives and and he asked for me to call
them back
it took me
a few moments to to
even figure out if this was real um
you know did a quick google search try
to see if there was anything in the news
yet which there wasn't at that point um
but
realized very quickly i needed to
actually call this person back um
the rabbi picked up the phone and then
quickly passed the phone to the gunman
who
um i i realized very quickly this was
not a crank call that this was real and
and um
and terrifying and essentially the
gunman um
took hold of a
really age-old anti-semitic trope that
jews kind of basically
control
uh government and control others and are
have
you know outsized influence this sort of
kind of conspiracy theory model of
jewish
power and um
he called me um he had done some
internet research because maybe because
i lead central synagogue and central
sounds like it's sort of the center he's
from england and he they're in england
they have a chief rabbi i think he was
looking for the equivalent
and um he saw a picture of me when i
went to the white house pictured with
obama so he was like you you know the
president you know obama um
honestly i'm not really sure why he
picked me but he believed
he believed that i could free
um a person he called his sister
although she wasn't his sister but who
uh
a terrorist who had been convicted and
was sitting in a federal prison 20
minutes from that synagogue in texas and
so he basically gave me an hour to
free her and bring her to the synagogue
and he said if you do that then then
everyone can stay safe and if you don't
well i have a bomb strapped in my
backpack and i've got bombs in new york
and i have bombs in brooklyn
um
i wasn't sure about the bombs in new
york and brooklyn but i was quite
certain that this man
had a gun and probably a bomb with him
and that he he was prepared to die that
was very clear he said that he said that
on the phone several times i love death
more than you love life
and um
i mean it was a it was a surreal um
you know um
terrifying responsibility um i i felt
completely responsible for these four
people's lives um even as i
knew in my mind
that i was
mostly powerless to do anything like the
the the little that i could control was
buying some time
um hoping to keep him calm
making assurances until someone could
come and save them which i thought could
be quickly because i quick because i had
already heard that police were on the
scene there um you know as as the as the
situation unfolded it took 11 hours
before um
the they actually freed themselves with
the rabbi throwing a chair at the tear
at the gunman and running out the door
and um you know and the fbi coming in
and ultimately um killing the gunman so
it was it was a really um
unreal situation i think that uh
it it made i think every jew around the
world um felt that they were held
hostage for those 11 hours with them i
mean we were watching in a way from
israel to france to everywhere in
america um i think it was and i and i
think that many americans you didn't
have to be jewish to feel the terror of
that um
the horror of
of um his demands and you know it was i
think he
i think it's pretty clear there's a man
who suffered from some mental illness
which his family concurred but he was
spouting
out like anti-semitic which he had
learned and which is
too much in you know not just in the air
but too much in the news even it's been
mainstreamed these ideas and that was
part of what was so frightening um you
know i think i felt personally very
vulnerable in those in those moments um
certainly not as much as the four that
were being held hostage but um
you know and i think that we're still
processing what it means i think to to
live in a world which is like that and
and you know
some of that same kind of anti-semitism
which fuels white supremacy
is some of the stuff that is being
spouted by uh the gunman from buffalo
that like you know i think for us to
think that that kind of rhetoric
um
doesn't turn violent um you know is to
not look at history and to not be honest
with ourselves so this has to be the
kind of thing that is
um
you know not just it has to be
wiped out
immediately upon hearing and i think
there's been way too much acceptance of
this kind of rhetoric and under the
guise of sort of free speech
i think it's i think it's very
threatening yeah
well first of all i just appreciate you
taking us through that as well obviously
that was a difficult situation while it
was happening i imagine not necessarily
easy to kind of walk through it again
but i just don't want to acknowledge
that first all of all but then also just
to thank you for
just sharing the important lessons with
us as well especially as you've talked
about the rhetoric um because it again
is so has so many practical
outputs and outcomes even in the same
way that we talked about on the other
side just the impactfulness of the
policies that allows you to walk into
the role that you are in a lot of ways
now but on the other side
the power of the rhetoric that can do
the complete opposite and lead to loss
of life so i mean i think it's really
important and healthy for us to kind of
hold both of those
together and just to think about ways
that we can continue to move forward um
so i appreciate you you know being
willing to go to that level and just all
that you did in that situation as well i
mean just the the quick thinking and
having to process and navigate
simultaneously is not an easy place to
be
yeah well i mean but part of what you're
lifting up which i think is a thread
that i hadn't really thought about as
much as just
we often think of any of these
situations whether it's
me being kind of like oh look there's
like the first asian rabbi and she's a
woman and it's sort of like almost like
a like an unusual case um and and on the
flip side it's sort of the negative you
you take someone like this gunman you
say he's like a lone wolf he's this
crazy one singular person who does this
what we actually often ignore are the
systemic
underpinnings that allow either the kind
of maybe exceptional case in a good way
or the exceptional case in a dangerous
violent way that they're it's almost no
one is a lone wolf there are there are
um
systems and um and biases and tropes and
all sorts of stuff that kind of like
inform a person that gets gets them to
that place so i think that with the
buffalo shooter with this gunman he he
acted alone perhaps in that moment but
he did not come to his views which was
so dangerous i mean both of those guys
were absolutely premeditating their acts
one drove 200 miles to the grocery store
this one came all the way from england
and bought an airplane ticket and worked
his way down to that specific synagogue
that was the closest synagogue he could
find to the prison um that he wanted to
free the prisoner from so like it was
highly premeditated so even if it was
singular there was a whole structure
around him thinking that this was what
he had to do he didn't go to the church
that was close to that federal prison he
went to the synagogue for a very
specific reason so i think that like
those kinds of things that we have to
think about and it can happen in the
positive way too that you can have um
cases that come up but i know that i was
supported by a whole structure of
policies and
mentors and um
communities that sort of like
taught me and helped me understand what
was possible and and then and then
enabled all those things to be possible
right so
um anyway
those things matter really well said
yeah yeah and then in a sense it puts
onus of all of us yes members of our
communities to think about the influence
that we have
with every single person around us i
mean i often talk about that if i'm
giving a talk around mental health
advocacy because i think we don't often
all think about ourselves as influencers
because that reward has been
so miserable
yeah i don't even know if i want to go
there but at the same time i often try
and challenge people think about well
who are the people immediately around
you and how do they react when you talk
about specific things so obviously i'm
i'm oftenly painting that in terms of
mental health but how do you talk about
mental health you talk about it
pejoratively and does that rub off on
those around you do they also talk about
that way so that when someone now runs
into a mental health challenge
it's seen as completely negative because
that's the culture and the atmosphere
that we've talked about that and i think
you're saying that in the same way as
well
first is do we talk about things in ways
that are hopeful or informed by by truth
and
healing and and opportunities for
community because all that will have
effects and sometimes i mean that can be
too weird to think about all the time
but i think we often times ignore that i
mean myself i can think about that as
well we often ignore that
and we just need to pay that much more
attention to it to think about all the
lies that we're influencing around us
because it will have these larger
implications and i think you know
everything that you've shared on both
sides has really highlighted that as
well
yeah
so a lot a lot for us a lot for us to
think about um and again just
i guess i'm feeling also at the same
time it's it's challenging because i
feel grateful and then also a weight of
responsibility in a sense i'm grateful
because i feel like and this is this is
going to sound like self-promotion but
just the ways we've been able to do that
on this podcast with so many people who
have been able to share
the ways that they're having impact
locally you know in their families and
their communities but then also on much
larger scales and nationally as well and
just as much as we can continue to
elevate both the small and the big
things that are happening i think are
just so important for us and i feel like
you've been doing that in this
conversation too just even in the way i
keep going back to
the things that you mentioned about the
shabbat and just the community and peace
that's there i mean i almost in a sense
and this is my
sorry it's my addiction related research
coming out again but i feel like i have
a craving for that type of atmosphere in
that environment and thinking about ways
to be more proactive about trying to
include aspects of that um in my own
life because that it's easy for that to
slip without that discipline and
dedication as well so again a lot of
full circle moments that i'm having in
this conversation i'm just reflecting
on many of the things that you're
sharing as well
yeah i did also just want to end just
talking a little bit about hope because
we've alluded to it a lot as we've been
going through the conversation you've
talked about things that have been
giving you hope even in your role and in
amongst your congregants but i'm curious
just what that word means to you on a
day-to-day basis i'm in the midst of
everything that we experience and in the
midst of everything that you do
well um
[Music]
i ended my
sermon the week after colleyville
sharing a blessing that is part of our
tradition and it is a blessing that we
say
before we read from the book of
lamentations limitations that maybe the
saddest book of the bible um and it's
about jerusalem being sacked and
destroyed she's imagery of like a woman
that's soiled it's like a it's a
terrible um terribly horrible piece and
it is red before the ninth day of the
month of of which is the day of the
destruction of not only the first temple
but also the second temple and then just
as the way that kind of like i don't
know religious coincidence works like
many other horrible things that have
ever happened to the jewish people have
happened on the ninth day of so it's
it's kind of a day of
a national day of mourning um
historic and current and
we read that book of lamentations on
this horrible day thinking about all the
terrible things that have happened to
the jews and we before we read that book
of lamentations we say a blessing um at
least in my community and we say that we
are
we are captives of hope
like it's such a such an amazing phrase
captive when you're captive to something
it's almost like you're being held
against your will
and despite yourself and
i there are times when it's very easy
for me to feel very hopeful um i'm a
generally optimistic person and then
there are times where i feel like it's
actually impossible and yet
i'm i'm a captive of hope i i think that
that is what we're called to be in a
sense um the text i think is originally
from jeremiah but that phrase but this
idea that we um we have no choice um but
to be held to that expectation and we
cannot give in to the kind of the
fashion of the day to despair um we
can't afford that so i think that that's
that's my general take sometimes it
comes more easily than others yeah i
love that phrase and i'm definitely
going to carry that with me
out of this conversation and hopefully
keep that in my in my spirit so to speak
so
again they're preaching
you're a kindred
captive of hope
i will take that i will definitely take
that um i i i think that it's
true in a lot of ways and
honestly it's been you know having
people like you on this podcast has been
a general reminder of that
as people have shared their reasons for
hope and the ways that they've seen
things move the ways that people have
allowed them to remain in that place and
so i definitely definitely take that and
accept that as well so
well again on that note just want to
thank you for taking the time especially
with all the responsibilities the role
that you have and the things that you
continue to do i really appreciate
one that we were able to be connected
through dr chu and two that you uh took
up that offer to connect and just talk
through this conversation and we've
touched on so many important things um
and i do say this every once in a while
but this is one of those conversations i
know i'm just gonna have to go back and
listen to and just pull out so many
different pieces and reminders that
we've had along this conversation so
definitely appreciate you being here
joining on the addie hour i know the
listeners are going to get a lot of this
conversation as well
thank you so much for having me of
course
[Music]